اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان اي اتفاق سيتم
التوصل اليه بشان الملف النووي يجب ان
يحمي مصالح مصالح ايران
ويراعي الخطوط الحمراء وقال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعان ان ايران
لا تجري اي مباحثات لابرام اتفاق النووي
مؤقت او جديد وان اي تفاوض يجب ان يكون
على اساس اتفاق 2015
واشار ايضا الى احتماليه حدوث تبادل
للسجناء مع واشنطن قريبا اذا اظهرت
الولايات المتحده حسن النيه استدل
منزليه ما هو مؤسسه
التصريحات الصادره عن الخارجيه الايرانيه
جاءت بعد ان فتح المرشد الايراني علي
خميني الباب امام امكانيه ابرام اتفاق مع
الغرب حول انشطه بلادها النوويه حيث قال
ان هذا الامر ليس مستحيلا لكنه شدد على
ضروره الا يمس ببنيه بلاده التحتيه
لانشطتها النوويه موافقه خامنئي الحدره
جاءت بعد ايام من نفي كل من طهران مباشر
صحه تقرير ذكر انهما
تقتربان من ابرام اتفاق مؤقت تكبح بموجبه
ايران برنامجها النووي مقابل تخفيف
العقوبات
ومع ذلك طالب مني هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه بمواصله العمل مع الوكاله
الدوريه للطاقه الذريه في اطار من
الضمانات داعيا الى عدم الرضوخ للمطالب
التي وصفها بالمبالغ فيها والخاطئه
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه حسب
تعبيرها
طالب باحترام قانون اقره البرلمان
الايراني في عام 2020
تعلق بموجبه طهران عمليات التفتيش التي
تجريها الوكاله الدوليه على المواقع
النوويه الايرانيه اذا لم ترفع العقوبات
اخيرا تم مؤخرا نشر اخبار حول الاتفاقيه
المؤقته او مواضيع من هذا القبيل نحن
نعتبر هذه التكهنات اعلاميه اكثر من اي
شيء اخر او ربما اخبارا تنشرها بعض
الاطراف بدوافع سياسيه خاصه بها او لتعطيل
العمليه الحاليه من المفاوضات ليس لدينا
ما يسمى التفاوض على اتفاقيه مؤقته ولا
نؤيد الترتيبات الجديده لتحل محل
الاتفاقيه نوويه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات